I usually don't have notes as you all
know I pretty much speak right off the
cuff but I had a list five things that
continue to prove that Donald Trump is
clearly not prepared to be President
United States commander in chief leader
of the free world it appears as though
when he does these events and people
press him he becomes unmoored and then
has to spend a lot of time trying to
figure out how to correct all the
mistakes that he made
and I have to tell you that as
commander-in-chief and leader of the
free world you don't get do-overs you
need to be able to get it right the
first time we know about his comments on
abortion which had put women in a very
difficult position and we know that he
has since moved to to correct those in
one way or another he actually talked
about the use of nuclear weapons both in
the Middle East and in Europe you wonder
about his hand or his thumb getting any
close to the critical button that
presidents are in charge of number three
he says that we should basically abolish
the Geneva Convention which was created
to make sure that we had fair treatment
for anybody who could be captured in war
and that somehow we ought to abolish the
Geneva Convention and engage in I guess
more more torture which doesn't sit well
with any of the people who have served
our country so honorably people like
like John McCain he's called on that
NATO basically to be abolished although
I can't figure out what his position is
today I happen to believe that NATO
needs to be strengthened NATO needs to
be strengthened and turned from a
basically solely a military organization
into a intelligence and policing
organization that can work across
borders and then one of the most curious
and I I don't even know how he went
there is that in picking the Supreme
Court justice that Donald Trump has
suggested that we have to that any
Supreme Court justice miss make a
commitment
to review and investigate Hillary's
emails I don't even know how you do that
that's something I can't even figure out